[Music]
yesterday how much [ __ ] himself
[Music]
looks as though they're dysley
[Music]
bili Eilish delivering an emotional in
memoriam tribute during Sunday's Academy
Awards this is about them you know
showing love she performed a cover of
yesterday by the Beatles alongside her
brother Phineas
[Music]
today
[Music]
she honored the lives of several beloved
crew members and entertainers like Doris
Day Peter Fonda Kirk Douglas who passed
away earlier this week and of course
Kobe Bryant whose photo holding his own
Oscar from 2017 opened the tribute with
this quote next to his picture life is
too short to get bogged down and be
discouraged you have to keep moving you
have to keep going I know they've added
something special for Kobe can you tell
us anything or how did you how did that
affect your planning I mean it's just
because when we were in rehearsal and
they run kind of what's going to be
playing it's like every time I see his
face I'm like et spoke of Billy on the
red carpet just hours before her
performance I don't want it to be about
me I don't know how to be watching the
screen watching the people and you know
it's a very listen it's a great thing to
do but it's a very difficult thing to do
is
my home so I'm really looking forward to
life I guess respectful reached and
respecting everybody has passed this
year two celebs seemingly left out of
the in memoriam Luke Perry who had a
part in Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
which scored several Oscar nom and
Disney star Cameron boys yesterday
how much woohoo see yourself
[Music]
looks as though they're dysley
study
[Music]